hello everybody and welcome to part 13
of our practical flask tutorial series
in this video what we're talking about
is creating our registration page for
our Grand user system that we're making
so we've got the login form but in order
to kind of move forward with the login
form we need to compare it against a
database of usernames and passwords so
before we have a database of usernames
and passwords we need a way to actually
populate that database and also we
actually populate the database we have
to create that database so let's go
ahead and get started so the first thing
that we're going to need to do is we're
going to need to access the database
that we already have now if you've been
following along you already have the my
sequel database basically like the my
sequel stuff and the server so you've
got the development and the server so if
you don't have my sequel server my
sickled dev you go ahead and get those
otherwise if you've been following along
you're ready to get started so first to
connect to our my sequel database what
we're going to type here is going to be
my sequel and that's just notifying that
that's the program we want to run and
then we're going to say - - user equals
and right now the only my sequel user
that we have is the root user now don't
confuse root here with your root user to
your server they're just called root
because it's like the main you know like
super admin user okay so use a root but
that's a different root and then you're
going to need to - P for password and
that's basically it right now so you'll
hit enter and it'll ask you for your
password again this is the password to
the root user of your my sequel database
not the password to your root user to
your server so hopefully you remember
what the root users password is I forget
the full list of instructions to do if
you forget your root user password but
I've done it in the past and it's
actually freakishly simple to reset the
root user password as long as you have
access to the root user to the server
so keep that in mind and in fact I'm not
even sure honestly actually I didn't
even I think I did it without access to
a root user even it was just a pseudo
user to reset the database password and
it's like I don't know ten steps or
something it's very short anyway enough
on that google it if you forget i'm not
going to cover that here so anyways i'm
going to enter my password and my
password was cookies exclamation mark no
reason to hide it from you because
you're going to see it very soon so now
we're connected to the to my sequel and
one thing you can do you can do show
databases for example and show databases
all caps semicolon and then here the
current databases these are just the
default they're going to be there for
everyone now what we want to do is we
actually want to create well first of
all we want to create so you've got
you've got databases and then you've got
tables okay so first what we want to do
is we want to create the the database so
first you've got it a database so we're
going to do create database and then you
can name the database I'm going to name
this database Python programming like
that semicolon and that's it okay that's
done one row affected now when it comes
to my sequel and databases and tables it
can be really confusing most people if
they're not used to working with
databases they actually can they they're
in their mind the database is is what is
actually a table so a table is what is
like the spreadsheet like with rows and
columns okay that's a table and then a
conglomeration of tables is what makes
up your database so keep that in mind so
we've got the database that's made but
you don't insert rows and columns into a
database you insert them into a table so
now we create a table now when you
create a table you specify all the
things in the attributes of that table
you can come by later on and modify that
but it's best to go ahead and use them
for site and for the most part that I
can recall anytime modify the table I've
actually copied and copied the table
over
to a new table that I created so it's
kind of a hassle if you want to change
anything so use some foresight into what
your needs are going to be so for me
we're going to do create table users and
I will just say you know first year guy
and say user table and um like myself
included like I'm thinking maybe I might
want to add a forum to Python
programming net but if you had a forum
you've got some extra things that you'd
track in a database really simply like
posts post count join date you know
stuff like that that doesn't necessarily
have to be in the users table and in
fact you might save on a lot of
processing by not leaving it all in one
table and using local tables with data
as long as you don't have too much copy
data you know the user name might be the
same but the actual data contained in
that table as long as there's not too
much overlap then you're probably better
off that way
so anyways create table users so that's
the name of the table and then now we're
going to specify the columns within it
so the first column is going to be UID
that's going to be a user ID and that
will be an integer so use capital int
for integer and it is going to be 11
long at its max so we've got UID integer
then we're going to say this hat is Auto
increment and it is also a primary key
next we have a user name oops
under case that user name username is
going to be a bar car which is a
variable character this means for
example we're saying 20 it was just car
it would always have 20 lengths no
matter what this is saying it can be any
length up to 20 after that done can't be
any longer
so we're saying basically we're saying
user names can be 1 to 20 long and then
now you've got user names now we want to
add
passwords so this will be Savarkar 20
then we've got comma password this will
be a bar car 100 i know 50 is probably
good enough but 100 is definitely good
enough for a password
then we'll have email possibly right now
um I can't remember if I collect emails
or not I don't I don't think I even do
I'm not positive I think yeah emails one
of the options you just we don't
validate by email right now anyway email
VAR car 50 if you have a longer email
and 50 something's wrong with you
settings and so here's one where
settings right now at least at the time
of me filming this video actually
contains nothing okay
settings has no use right now for me I
don't change anything or modify but you
can kind of conceive that in the future
you might allow users to I don't know
have some sort of settings on your
website that you want to change so
things like suggestions or maybe the
color scheme of the website so you know
stuff like that you might want to change
so settings that's a pretty common one
people are going to have settings on
websites so that's kind of me using some
foresight that we might eventually want
settings vark are 30 to 500 basically
we're allowing that to be really really
really long and next we're going to say
tracking and this is again vark are 30
to 500 so what's happening here is the
tracking is basically what tutorials has
that user already done and so we use
tracking to update things like percent
complete and then possibly in the future
used it for things like suggested
tutorials stuff like that based on the
tutorials that you've completed we can
kind of deduce or induce that you might
be interested in another topic something
like that so anyways tracking and then
finally right now again it doesn't have
any bearing on my website but it is in
my database and that is rain
it's an integer and up and it can be
three long so basically that's four you
know let's say a typical user let's say
if there's some sort of way to upgrade
your user to say a moderator ok and then
you've got admin user then maybe super
admin in that kind of stuff so you might
want to have user ranks in there also
you could give people rank based on the
amount of tutorials that they complete
all kinds of stuff that you could
possibly do here so that's that and then
of course end with a semicolon that's
kind of a long list of stuff that we've
just added but hopefully it makes sense
if you have any questions about anything
mostly we're using varkari here the only
thing I will say is this is really and
if well it's not inefficient I want to
say but this is not the best most
efficient method especially the massive
bar cards we are allowing here and then
there's also things like blobs and uh I
forget there's like big text or
something I can't remember all the all
the things but there's there's like
probably like five different data types
or more that you can pass through as a
column you know type and depending on
what you're doing each one will be
slightly different as far as how useful
it is to you and how efficient it is to
you in processing for our uses this
table is not like a high input output
table it's not referenced at a high rate
or by a large rate so this is good
enough and actually as we'll see later
on through the lack of use of my sequel
on Python programming Diamont
are processing on that website is
actually next to nothing I'm paying less
than I did whenever I was using a mmm
WordPress and there were I mean you
could make a user account on that
WordPress but most people didn't so I
already have more users on Python
program in it than I did on WordPress
anyways and that's including bots
anyways
hit enter hopefully uh oh darn luckily
we can use the up-arrow and we want to
do anything but anyway when you connect
to a database the first thing you have
to do is you gotta use
use that database so we created that
database but we're not using that
database so you use flips all caps use
Python programming or whatever you call
it the database now our database changed
and now uh you could do show tables but
we don't have any tables it's an empty
set as it says but now up arrow up arrow
up arrow let's create that table okay
now let's do show tables and now we have
users and we can do something like this
like if you forget maybe what are my
column names in your in your table you
can use what's called describe and you
can describe users and this will tell
you basically all there is to know about
your whatever table you use so the field
the type is it know like do Willi will
we allow that value to be null key
you've got a primary key default null
nothing and then any extra parameters
this is an auto increment so the first
user will just automatically be one and
the next one will be two we won't ever
actually need to specify and say hey
this user is UID
two or three or whatever so that's that
we've got now our database but we have
nothing in it but of course you could do
things like you select all from users
like this it just so happens to be that
there's nothing there but soon there
might be there you could update and you
could you know insert all kinds of SQL
commands right in here but we're not
going to do that we're not really
interested in doing it via the command
line we want our program our flask
application to do it so in order to get
our flask application to do it we're
going to need a new module and then
we're going to make an actual connection
scripts that will connect to our DB for
us and then we can use that within our
init script and all that so that's what
you guys have to look forward to if you
have any questions or concerns or
comments or whatever up to this point
please feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thank you for
watching thanks for all the support of
the subscriptions and so next time